التحضيرات تاتي تباعا من علماء ومتنبئين
بالزلازل فيما يخص زلزال كبير قد يضرب
اسطنبول المدينه التركيه الشهيره خبير
الزلازل التركيه ناجيجورور حذر من وقوع
زلزال مدمر في المدينه التاريخيه قد تفوق
شدته عشر درجات على مقياس ريختر على حد
تعبير الخبير التركي دعا عمده اسطنبول
لاستخدام العلم من اجل تقليص الخسائر التي
قد تقع في المدينه خصوصا في قسمها الاسيوي
حيث يكون الجانب الاكثر تضررا في وقت
تستمر فيه توقعات العالم الهولندي الذي
مازال لا يعتقد ان زلزالا اخر قد يضرب
المنطقه التي شهدت قبل نحو شهر زلزالا
مدمرا شمال مناطق عده في جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا
يعني هذه المره نتحدث عن زلزال عشر درجات
عن مقياس رختر يكون سلسله كثير قوي يعني
الزلزال السابق كان 7.8 وحصل كل هالدمار
بنحكي عن 45 الف قتيل ما بين سوريا وتركيا
بس 10 درجات اسطنبول يعني هذا امر مقلق
ومخيف نتمنى ان لا يحصل والا تصدق هذه
التنبؤات